joining us now the other senator from
Florida Democratic Senator Bill Nelson
senator I've heard you react today but
you listen to those students and your
thoughts as you're getting the number of
fatalities from authorities down there
when I was on your colleagues show
Shepard Smith earlier this afternoon I
knew it was many fatalities and I didn't
want to jump the gun and said a number
of fatalities and as you start to
confirm the number it comes in our worst
fears are realized and of course you
grieve you just think how those parents
are grieving how there's school
officials and there may be a school
teacher
among those fatalities you can imagine
what they're going through and my
thoughts and I've already prayed for
comfort for all of our people down in
Broward County listening to the school
superintendent senator this was a joyous
day that were celebrating the Teacher of
the Year in Broward County she got a new
car and then he was driving and got word
of this of this shooting I understand
it's the biggest shooting in in Broward
County's history and and now with this
fatality will likely be one of the
biggest in the nation remember it was
just a year ago that we had the shooting
and the Fort Lauderdale Airport the very
same County remember it was just a few
months ago the mass shooting in Las
Vegas and you can go all the way back to
Sandy Hook and then beyond that back to
Columbine Brett what does it take for us
to come to our senses and a civilized
and loving people to stop this mass
murder yeah I guess that's the question
you know in the politics of this and
fighting about how to get to a solution
on this day it is it's tough to see how
you can stop it as it is now is that the
access to the guns is it the mental
health aspect of things we don't know
the answers to what motivated this kid
do you have anything from authorities
about this suspect and what what was
behind any of this no and of course the
investigation will bring all of that out
but you've asked the right questions was
it legal to purchase it was it a
high-capacity caliber weapon
was he treated in some way for a mental
health condition all of the above are
things that ought to be examined and
ought to be try to be dealt with in the
future in this current environment is
that going to happen
well when you consider as I shared with
Shepard Smith earlier when you consider
that Diane Feinstein had a bill that we
voted on that was just simply to take
the terrorist watch list of terrorists
and put a prohibition that they could
not buy a gun and that was defeated so I
don't know the answer to your question
breath final thought we're waiting on
authorities here obviously they have
their hands full down there trying to
piece all of this together but this is a
massive undertaking for the Broward
County Sheriff's Department if those
numbers end up like is being speculated
on the number of fatalities then indeed
this is one of the worst crimes and
tragedies that Florida has ever seen one
death is too many this may be multiple
well senator we appreciate your time
especially on a day like this that's
very tough to talk about thank you thank
you breath